Wisconsin residents are breathing easier
this morning an intensive search ended
Friday on a farm 125 miles northwest of
Janesville for a fugitive who allegedly
stole an arsenal of weapons and said he
wanted to commit violent acts against
the government here's DeMarco Morgan we
said all along we wanted a peaceful
resolution to this situation and today
we have that conclusion attending
manhunt involving more than 250 law
enforcement officers ended after a
farmer's spotted Joseph Jakubowski
camping on his property Jeffrey Gorn
spoke to jackubowski for about an hour
but then became suspicious the one thing
he said over and over is no one listens
to me jakubowski had the state of
Wisconsin on edge all week after
allegedly stealing 18 weapons and
sending an anti-government manifesto to
the White House police confiscated four
handguns a long rifle a samurai type
sword a bulletproof vest several boxes
of ammunition and a copy of his 161 page
manifesto Rock County Sheriff Roberts
potent this was a big deal this was
probably the largest manhunt in our
careers the FBI offered a
twenty-thousand-dollar reward for his
capture that led to more than 700 tips
regarding jackubowski swear about but it
only took one tip to find it it was a
good tip from the farmer Jakubowski is
no stranger to law enforcement he served
prison time for attacking and trying to
disarm a police officer eight years ago
he faced a federal judge and madison
earlier friday and is now and the rock
county jail for CBS this morning
saturday tomorrow Morgan Janesville
Wisconsin